the World Cup is about to get underway
and everybody's got their eyes on the
prize
[Music]
we're here at this party to celebrate
the arrival of the World Cup we've got
social media influencers we've got
members of the media we've got some VIPs
even
what we're going to do right now is talk
to someone who's involved in the
organization of this party
trophy tour is one of the great assets
and activations that we are doing
together before coming here to Doha we
have been to 51 countries so now we are
here in the host country and it's so
excited because this is actually the
official start of the World Cup I think
everyone's pumped for the World Cup here
in Qatar right DJ you pumps
well the big question is who's going to
win it the thing is we've been speaking
to someone who's won it before and he's
been telling us all about his experience
I still remember like it was yesterday
it's an amazing feeling and achievement
I was dreaming about it and I hold it I
was next to zidane when I hold it
it's like you're holding a baby you're
not scared to drop the baby you know how
to hold it you kiss it you are happy
it's something special it's been a great
night to celebrate the arrival of the
World Cup trophy the question is now
who's on a winner on December 18th we
shall see
[Music]